new home security video shows multiple
angles of the FBI's pre-dawn raid on the
home of political consultant Roger stone
unarmed 66 years old without a pass put
bare foot until now the only public
footage of the raid came from CNN which
somehow knew to arrive one hour before
the FBI got there acting Attorney
General Matthew Whitaker was asked about
the CNN footage in his testimony before
Congress today here's part of it are you
from a year from public force or
otherwise that a CNN reporter was camped
out outside of Stone's house when the
FBI arrested him this wouldn't be part
of investigations I am I am aware of
that and it was it was deep deeply
concerning to me as to how CNN found out
about that I share your concern with the
possibility that a media outlet was
tipped off to mr. stones either
indictment or arrest before it was made
that information was available to the
public the new footage from Stone's home
shows CNN arriving about an hour before
agents did the footage depicts what
you'd expect if the FBI raided the home
of a Mexican drug lord maybe even SEAL
Team six going to bin Laden's compound
for contacts Roger stone is a senior
citizen accused of false statements to
Congress take a look at what happened
it's just before 5:00 a.m. at an SUV
with a CNN cameraman arrives first to
this quiet street in Fort Lauderdale
Florida within minutes the driver gets
out and begins to set up his tripod so
far no sign that anything's about to
happen but the camera gets back in his
car with his equipment to wait
almost exactly one hour later trucks
with heavily armed men arrived in front
of Roger stones house immediately CNN's
cameraman jumps out of the car camera on
shoulder capturing the footage
the feds assemble on stones driveway
they're wearing ballistic armor and
carrying assault weapons with 30 round
magazines red dot sights and tactical
flashlights mounted to their barrel
shrouds one has his gun hanging by a
strap while he carries a battering ram
in his left hand all of the men have
sidearms holstered on their waists a
second camera mounted on stones front
door shows another angle of the raid a
heavily armed FBI agent approaches the
door with his gun drawn
while others stakeout positions behind
it looks like a high-stakes raid but
CNN's cameraman is still 40 feet away
filming a tall one agent swings his
firearm around as he scans and surveys
stones front porch behind the home a
third camera captures agents approaching
the back of the house from the side yard
behind the property a boat arrives with
at least two agents on board they shine
a floodlight
into stones home back in front an agent
pounds on stones door finger next to the
trigger in case something goes wrong he
tries again as he and his colleagues
wait in position within minutes stone
exits his home to greet the agents who
have their rifles pointed at him stone
raises his hands and spins around
apparently trying to show that he is
unarmed another FBI agent approaches
stone from behind and cuffs him it's
just after six o'clock in the morning
it's still dark out 20 minutes later the
same camera shows agents leading Roger
stone back into his house he is barefoot
stone is wearing a t-shirt that says
Roger stone did nothing wrong
[Music]
the FBI and their water carriers in
corporate media tell us totally
commonplace by-the-book happens all the
time